hi I'm Ryan and tonight we're gonna be
watching the trailer for transformers
age of extinction honestly I don't like
any of the Transformers movies I think
all very boring
I appreciate this visual effects
big-time the action looks cool too I
just think they're very boring films for
some reason it's like incredibly like
what is the point of the trilogy these
bad guys
the Decepticons come to earth and then
the Autobots are fighting their own war
and humans are just caught up in the
middle of all this [ __ ] and it's like
why don't you just go fight somewhere
else
like why does have to be earth did story
never wraps up it's just them continuing
the war every [ __ ] movie and it's
like this is never gonna come to an end
and why I'm the third one that they want
to enslave humans like these are [ __ ]
incredible beings and what good would
they have with humans like what do they
think they're gonna get productive
things that yeah I mean it's like
they're obviously more equipped and
talented and then anyway it's I just
think it's stupid but Mark Wahlberg's on
this and I love Marky Mark hopefully
this one intrigues me more than the
other ones there's a thing about
Transformers movies every time I see the
trailer I'm like that film looks [ __ ]
cool then I watch it and I get really
tired I fell asleep in the second one
and the third one yeah give me a damn
good reaction cool oh she's so hot
who is she
telogen trailer looks so [ __ ] cool
that's pretty badass there's a dress she
okay
those creatures got me excited I think
I've heard about them Dinobots or some
[ __ ] or am I making that up
anyway yeah I know those creatures look
pretty [ __ ] cool and there's
interesting scene a transformer user
parachute that was gonna get jets and
numbers on [ __ ] but yeah that looks
promising that's what I always say when
I watch the trailer she was [ __ ]
franchise it was looks really cool but I
think mixing it up with Mark Wahlberg
hell yeah man hell yeah Michael Bay and
him did a good job together I'm painting
game and this is the same exact kind of
thing